you know I've talked about cryotherapy
which is cold therapy taking a cold
shower
but sauna bathing I think can give you
almost as many benefits and today we're
going to talk about what would happen if
you were to do
sauna on a regular basis for 14 days I
think you can create a huge change in
your overall health now what happens
when you go into the sauna is you have
this interesting
thermal therapy benefit of your body
adapting to this mild stress and the
term for that is called a harmonic
effect where you're adding a stress to
cause your body to then adapt and become
stronger now there are other things that
can give you this hermetic effect like
cold showers or the ice tubs fasting
exercise but let's dive into the
benefits of what this sauna can give you
now you have the regular sauna where
you're adding heat but then you also
have another type of sauna which is not
as hot where they're using infrared
which is a little bit different that can
go a little bit deeper into the body
because of this infrared can penetrate
inside the body and it can also increase
more melatonin but in this video I want
to primarily focus in on the benefits of
a regular heated sauna situation so
let's first talk about what it can do to
your hormones it can definitely increase
growth hormone by 140 percent it can
increase nor adrenaline which is a
hormone from your adrenal glands it can
significantly increase dopamine which
can actually make you calmer and affect
your mood it can increase serotonin
which can also affect your mood and even
increase your prolactin which is another
hormone but let's go through some of the
other benefits number one it can help
lower your resting heart rate okay now
the more the person exercises the more
athletic they become the lower the
resting heart rate and that can
definitely decrease your risk for all
sorts of cardiovascular problems and
extend your life so having a lower
resting pulse rate is a good thing
number two it can help your lymphatic
system and it's kind of like a backup
reserve for your vascular system and
it's a place where your immune system
hangs out with all the lymph nodes and
so a sauna can actually help stimulate
the lymphatic system so even though the
pulse rate will increase during the
summer like you're working out over a
period of time your body will adapt to
this and give you a lower resting pulse
rate to roughly about 120 beats per
minute so you're actually getting your
heart to pump you're getting better
circulation more lymph flow and the
therapeutic effect from a sauna can
actually mimic what you would get from
doing moderate aerobic exercise which is
pretty pretty interesting because you're
not actually running you're just sitting
there it has some pretty cool effects on
lowering your blood pressure it can
decrease the intensity and the risk of
getting an asthmatic event it can
actually strengthen your immune system
so you don't get sick as often and this
next one is quite remarkable they have
found that it decreases all cause
mortality in one study by 40
if you're doing a sauna four to seven
days a week so just that one little
benefit alone kind of makes you want to
go into the sauna sauna therapy can
actually help reduce pain
inflammation it can actually help
certain skin problems like psoriasis it
can give you something that can help you
recover over stress and even exercise
sonotherapy can give you significant
cognitive benefits which is really cool
it can actually decrease the severity of
dementia too another cool benefit that
relates to a lot of other side benefits
is it can increase insulin sensitivity
so it actually is helping you with your
blood sugars it decreases something
called roths which has to do with
oxidative stress so it kind of has an
antioxidant effect it makes your skin
look youthful and it's probably a
combination of both the Hermetic effect
from the Heat and as well as the
circulation as well as autophagy okay so
the sonotherapy can stimulate autophagy
which is this recycling of old damaged
proteins which is pretty cool now you're
going to be sweating in the sauna so let
me just kind of cover what happens when
you sweat
you're going to be losing mostly uh
sodium with a smaller amount of
potassium an average person consumes
about 3 300 milligrams of sodium every
single day and that's about a thousand
milligrams over what they should be
consuming okay which is about 2300 now
this doesn't take into consideration
sweating and exercise okay but on
average they consume a certain amount of
potassium which is usually more than
they should but a lot of that is
dependent on your potassium levels
because an average person consumes only
about 2600 milligrams of potassium and
they need 4 700 a lot more
so sodium does not become a problem if
you have enough potassium but here's the
thing when you go into the sauna you're
going to be sweating out mostly your
sodium and so the sodium is going to go
down and down and down and so depending
on if you have too much sodium you might
feel better let's say for example you're
doing this long fast right where you
need more sodium or you're doing the
ketogenic diet where you need more
sodium and you then do this sauna
treatment and you sweat it out yet
you're also not getting enough potassium
now you can end up with a electrolyte
imbalance so anytime you're doing the
sauna take in consideration the sweating
and so make sure you're getting enough
electrolytes you might need a little bit
more potassium you might need more
sodium with that but you want to balance
those things out so those are some
pretty cool benefits of the sauna
treatment you might want to try it and
since we're on the topic of sodium and
potassium I put this video up right here
check it out